hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcasting
i'm just checking in
on you
how are you how's your week going what's
up i have one more week on the movie and
then we're wrapped
i cannot believe it um
very excited
i am as excited as some of my listeners
were upset that i didn't talk about the
incident
at the oscars it was funny somebody
[ __ ] wrote to me was going like i
told you you're the [ __ ] poke you
hear your reaction to the slap
hollywood's made you soft and i was like
so you turned into my podcast to listen
about gossip
about an award award show and i'm the
[ __ ] one that's soft i'll be honest
with you guys uh i'm still not gonna
talk about it because i'm still trying
to figure out
you know
that [ __ ] brought up a lot of [ __ ] for
me
beyond being a comedian
but um
yeah i will at some point i just didn't
want to be yet another person
you know [ __ ] typing in all capital
letters flipping the [ __ ] out screaming
yelling and none of that's doing
anything for anybody
uh
i actually sat down at a long talk with
my lovely wife last night
about that [ __ ] took me [ __ ] back
took me [ __ ]
back and uh i gotta say the
the way chris handled that moment was
[ __ ]
unbelievable and the restraint that he
showed because
he starts to go like oh i could say and
he and the fact that he didn't
because it was lobbed over the net at
that point um for the daryl dawkins
break the backboard slam but then who
knows what happens after that and i felt
he chose the show in the event
over
you know
pride and ego and all of that stuff so
um yeah at some point you know
i'll sort it out but i don't know
whatever jesus [ __ ] christ i also
loved quest and i felt that the whole
evening was taken away from everybody so
you know i don't know
have you checked out summer assault
it's a positive thing to say
anyway um
uh what i don't know what the [ __ ] to
talk about let's talk march madness
everybody
nah
nah nah nah i know what the march mad
song is all you know it's uh this
shining moment when you win we got in
the final four
you got villanova
didn't they used to be in the big east
villanova kansas jayhawks
one of my favorite college basketball
programs you got the north carolina tar
heels
and then you got got to have probably
the fan favorite if you love greatness
coach k in his final year at at duke
wrapping up
one of the greatest basketball
coaching careers of all time 42 years at
duke
and he gets a second chance at carolina
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i don't know why people waste time
watching soap operas and real housewives
stuff the level of [ __ ] drama that is
in sports and it's actually real
you know it is now until the gambling
gets out of control and then it all
becomes
fixed like beyond fixed
um by the way i think i'm on to
something with that whole um
degenerate uh
part of every stadium they should have
you know what i mean you know like
amsterdam has their red light district
they should just have a red light
district and every stadium and you just
keep adults who don't know how to behave
and restrain themselves
in that section away from the kids and
the families
and you know the old guys who like to
keep score now
in that section i'm not saying there's
going to be hookers i'm not saying
there's not going to be
okay
this is a blank slate um
i want you guys to weigh in here i want
to know what you want in the red light
district
of your ballpark and because you're
going to be able to go up there and be a
complete degenerate
because you're going to be up there with
all the class clowns and the summer
school
[ __ ] kids all the people that they
don't allow to shout [ __ ] out at games
anymore they try to shut them down by
playing loud [ __ ] on tv screens the
second the action stops
which takes all the [ __ ] personality
of the neighborhood of the city you're
in they've completely
just gotten rid of it
with these goddamn loud [ __ ] tv
screens every time the [ __ ] whatever
game you're watching stops
um you got to be in the upper deck
i think like upper deck rightly right
field or left field
you're glassed in
tinted glass no one can see what's going
on in there
and i think inside
mine you can gamble
you can drink
you can smoke
that's the biggest one for me all right
you can smoke
there's different tiers of it like the
four floors of [ __ ]
in um
the [ __ ] was that place
singapore
four floors of [ __ ] was this place
that they called
i'll never forget that the the lady
promoter invited me and my wife to go
over
just like ah no
gonna take a big uh pass on that one um
although having said that you know if i
wasn't married and i was with one of my
knucklehead friends back in the day i
absolutely would have gone i'm not
saying i'm a better person i'm just with
a better person now
um
yeah i think there should be like a
[ __ ] section
at the top
and i can actually
put together a good argument for this
okay aside from the one that i already
said about how you know
people get to yell out of ball games
again right it's a degenerate section
you don't participate
in all of that [ __ ] that goes on
on the big tv screen you can't even hear
it what happens when there's a stop at
your play is every all the class clowns
and all the [ __ ] knuckleheads and the
loudmouths the drunks the gamblers and
the smokers all talk about the game like
we used to before you other [ __ ]
[ __ ] showed up and ruined the
experience well it was never gambling
well there was everybody ran down to the
[ __ ] pay phone at halftime
um
no mascots
no t-shirts shot up there man that'd be
a [ __ ] great idea
you know they always have like vintage
stuff
buy like a minor league team
nah no one would let you do it and they
say well smoking's like bad for your
health it's like and
you're not going to say we're
overpopulated
we should just go back to viewing poppy
the population
is like you know just like the deer it
just needs to be
you know
it's just something that needs to be uh
what handled is that the [ __ ] word i
don't know i'm i'm losing my
concentration here because i'm hearing
the garbage truck coming up the street
and that's my thing i go right out there
are you like me do you go right out
there the second the garbage guy comes
by i go right out there
right out there with the regular right
out there with the recycling and right
out there with the landscaping one the
black the blue and the green barrels and
here's the thing
um i know they all end up in the same
pile put on a barge and dumped in the
middle of the ocean that's not what i'm
talking about the biggest one you have
to be there for is the black one the
regular
this isn't some progressive [ __ ] either
i mean the black trash barrel
all right
you got to be there for that one because
that's the one that these [ __ ] people
throw their dog [ __ ] bags in all right
people who have dogs i used to have a
dog i remember the best day was trash
day
all right the other six days of the week
your dog takes a [ __ ] you pick it up
you're walking around trying to find a
[ __ ] barrel you can put in it and
everybody's hiding their barrels because
they don't want your dog's dog [ __ ] in
their [ __ ] barrel just sitting in the
sun with the lid closed stinking up your
[ __ ] barrel so
my big move
is when that [ __ ] comes up the street
i run right out there and i already got
my the black and the blue one in this is
the green one
this is all right although some hippie
might walk by with their dog and be like
what man it's like compost
you know
um
anyway so who do you guys like in the
final four i like
um
i know caroline and duke are always so
evenly matched i feel like because
carolina won the last time
um i feel like duke's gonna get him but
i gotta tell you as a carolina tar heel
fan you gotta be thinking how [ __ ]
great would it be if the last two times
north carolina played duke they [ __ ]
beat duke both times and left that
[ __ ] stink
that bad taste in coach k's mouth
because you know they don't give a [ __ ]
carolina blue
[ __ ] state [ __ ] duke you know they're
saying that [ __ ] and then on the other
side you got kansas
villanova
i don't know [ __ ] about either team
other than i love the kansas jayhawks so
i'm gonna take kansas and then in the
final championship game if there's a
duke kansas
final i gotta i mean that's tough
because kansas is my team but i i just
have so much respect for coach k i got
to root for duke
the rest of the way out but i'm one of
those weird guys because i didn't grow
up down there in the carolinas
down there in the research triangle
down there in tobacco road
um
i
like carolina and i like duke
i like carolina because i always liked
their uniforms and then when i was
growing up they had like sam perkins and
uh
what's his face james worthy
michael jordan
j.r reed
eric montrose
i watched him all through all they had
uh uh what's his face there vince carter
they just had some incredible incredible
players
and
um
i always like duke also because i'm
white as [ __ ] and there's just something
about duke that just is white as [ __ ]
i mean that is a white [ __ ] school
um
anyway i just feel really comfortable on
that campus um anyway um i'm [ __ ]
with you guys and then kansas i always
liked
i don't know why i always liked that uh
i don't know i just always had like good
teams
and uh you know i have a lot of family
in the midwest and stuff and i always
loved the midwest
you know bob's big boy you know the
shakes had malt in them
you know back when you would travel and
[ __ ] was different instead of the same
10 [ __ ] stores i really enjoyed all
of that and uh
villanova now didn't villanova weren't
they the ones that went with rory
massimino or something like that then
they went in like 1995.
hang on a second
villanova
uh
was that them
85. championship roster yeah that was it
i remember that
yeah
who was their coach
who was their coach raleigh raleigh
massimino
um
and that was when georgetown was trying
to go back to back and they had that kid
michael graham i remember him
and patrick ewing
and st john's had chris mullen
syracuse had pearl washington we were
just talking about the big east was
[ __ ] amazing back then
and then virginia had uh ralph sampson
houston had akeem elijah on i mean it
was just [ __ ] the 80s were [ __ ]
ridiculous
carolina had michael jordan
um and duke was yet to be a powerhouse
and then kansas what did they have do
they have sam bowie or was he kentucky i
can't remember
and then he had [ __ ] bobby knight
in indiana and i know that they won one
like 87 or something like that i think
that the last that was like the last one
that they won i believe
um
which by the way bobby knight probably
fell asleep while will smith was
screaming
[Laughter]
he's probably sitting there going what
is this the [ __ ] disney channel
what am i supposed to do with this this
is boring as [ __ ]
um
anyways let's do a little bit of uh
reads here for
the week uh bet mgm it's tournament time
riff about college hoop excitement i
just did
i just all of that i was just riffing
about leads us into bet mgm
why just sit there and watch the game
when maybe you can make a little bit of
money
uh you know if you haven't signed up for
bet mgm yet use bonus code burr b-u-r-r
and you'll get 200 free after placing
your first 10 bet if any team hits a
three-pointer during the march matchup
uh oh if any team
wait you'll get 200 free after placing
your first 10 bet if any team hits a
three-pointer during march matchups
obviously they're just giving you that
money here's how it works number one
uno uh
um download the bet mgm app and sign up
using bonus code burr number two duh dos
i ain't i already never knew the german
is fine
um place your tenth your first 10 dollar
money line bet any march on any march
madness game number three trois
uh tres you you'll receive 200 in free
bets immediately after placing your bet
if any team hits a three-pointer during
march match matchups
regardless of the outcome just make sure
you use the bonus code bur when you sign
up visit bettmgm.com for terms and
conditions 21 plus years of age or older
to wage arizona colorado dc iowa
illinois indiana louisiana maryland
michigan mississippi new jersey nevada
new york pennsylvania tennessee virginia
west virginia or wyoming new customer
offer all promotions are subject to
qualification and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable free bets or site
credit three bets expire in seven days
from issuance excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem for arizona
call 1-800 next step colorado dc
louisiana nevada wyoming virginia call
1-800-522-4700 confidential help in
michigan 1-800-270-7117
illinois indiana maryland new jersey
pennsylvania wyoming 1-800 gambler iowa
1-800 that's off new york call 877-8
hope new york or text hope new york
tennessee call redline
one eight eight eight 800-889-97898
seven seven nine six nine six sports
betting's void in georgia hawaii ohio
utah and other states were prohibited
promotional offers not available in
nevada bowl and branch
good luck with that people in bet
responsibly
don't be a [ __ ] have fun
okay
don't end up marriage
bowling branch bowling branch sheets
aren't just
buttery
breathable and impossibly comfortable
they get softer with every wash forget
thread count bowling branch gives you
thread quality because it doesn't matter
how many threads your sheets have if
they aren't the best threads possible
oh there you go that makes sense
doesn't matter how many horses you got
if them horses won't run
uh the signature hem sheets from bowling
branch are considered
are a best seller for a reason bowling
branch i mean it just sounds doesn't
that just sound comfortable
that sounds like a steakhouse bowling
branch you know that's that's a good
idea steakhouse you just lay in a bed
it's a high thread count they just feed
your [ __ ] steak
you know defribulator right on the other
side of the bedpost bowling branch uses
the highest quality threads on earth
i like how they clarified with earth you
know as opposed to what the rest of the
solar system
they got something better on uranus
there
for a superior softness and a better
night's sleep sheets made with threads
so luxurious
uh they're beloved by three u.s
presidents
and uh i like the way they feel against
my balls
uh they feel buttery to the touch stop
saying buttery and are super breathable
so they're perfect for every season over
ten thousand stellar reviews bowling
branch signature sheets come in nine
versatile colors in all sizes from twin
up to a california king
what is a california king the way they
eat out here some emaciated person
plant-based diet you'll immediately feel
the difference of their iconic signature
sheets they're 100 free from toxins
meaning no pesticides formaldehyde or
other harsh chemicals bull and branch
sheets fit the deepest uh
of mattresses
the deepest of matt who sleeps on a deep
mattress
what does deep mean smart it's like a
crevice going down the middle
bowling branch sheets fit the deepest of
mattresses and are
labeled with top and bottom tags so
making your bed is easier than ever
isn't that nice
finally somebody decided to do that top
and bottom uh best of all bowling branch
gives you a 30 night risk free trial
with free shipping and returns on all
orders get 15 off your first set of
sheets when you use promo code bur
dot com that's bull and branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
b-r-a-n-c-h dot com promo code burr
oh bull land so you know i'm thinking
bowlin branch bull and
all right solo stove hey man do you like
to cook by yourself man no solo stuff
this is something different solo stove
there's nothing quite like the feeling
of gathering around a warm fire on a
cool evening and a smokeless fire pit
from solo stove makes your outdoor
movements even more memorable because
instead of having to constantly dodge
campfire fumes you can sit back relax
and actually enjoy the fire and right
now you can get a great deal on a solo
stove fire pit solar stove fire pits are
brilliantly engineered easy to light
with the fewer fewer with a few bits of
starter your fire is blazing in minutes
perfectly portable take solo stove with
you on camping trips and more shop now
and get up to 30 off
uh fire pits all month long and use
promo code burr at checkout to get an
extra 20 off plus a lifetime warranty
and free 30-day returns just go to solo
stove and remember you get 20 off when
you use promo code burr
all right there you go
and as always
old freckles is running out of [ __ ] to
talk about oh another thing happened to
me last week was i [ __ ] i did the
podcast before
um
the goddamn oscars happened
and i went to upload it
and for some reason my computer is not
recognizing my interface which is why
i'm still doing this thing on my podcast
but i did a whole tribute to uh taylor
hawkins and i forgot to do it the second
time around because that other [ __ ]
happened
so i got to go back here um
yeah rest in peace taylor hawkins man
um absolutely absolutely shocking
shocking news uh
oh man i don't even know what to say
just loved loved his playing his energy
just seemed like the coolest guy ever
and what i loved about him was his
influences like i thought like
he wasn't the typical guy saying bonham
keith moon you know
he was into like fleetwood mac
he was into the eagles he was into queen
he had the great singing voice and the
stage presence and all that then i also
thought he had like really cool
uh drum kits and stuff like i always
liked every time the foo fighters would
go out i was always excited
to see his kit that is really one of the
coolest things about um
[Music]
you know being a fan of drums and
drummers
is uh i guess guitar players and bass
players do it too but i feel like a lot
of guitar players play the same guitar
and then they get known for that guitar
and same with like a lot of like bass
players too like i know like duff
mckagan who i love he's been playing
that white bass with the skull and
crossbone he's been playing that [ __ ]
thing
since i first saw them on mtv live at
the ritz in like 88 or something
um
but i feel like drummers every tour
they're like all right i need a new kit
i gotta okay i gotta outdo the last one
or uh you know
i'm gonna go like vista light this time
um anyway but i always thought taylor
hawkins had really really cool like drum
kits
and um
i just loved the way he played and i
always feel like a drummer that can also
sing
makes him like an even even better
drummer as far as like
i don't know just having that gift to
also be able to sing i feel like you
understand
harmony and music at a deeper level and
it affects the way you play drums in a
good way
as opposed to a tone-deaf jackass like
myself that can just sit down and apply
his
you know weak athletic background to the
instrument you know what i mean i feel
like that guy was like a fully formed
musician
and um
yeah man what a [ __ ]
kick in the gut that is so
all right you know what a bad week
just a [ __ ]
awful week but uh we got to end a higher
note here um
you know i want to thank everybody that
i've been doing the movie with
you know miramax everybody on the uh
everybody i'm acting with all the
producers
just everybody the whole crew that's
shooting the thing the food trucks that
we've had we've had a [ __ ] at least i
have anyways i think everybody else is
having a good time having just a [ __ ]
blast making this movie
and um
i'm getting down to the end here and
this is when you get nervous as a
first-time director like how do i
assemble this thing and then i'm just
thinking back like every scene kind of
i felt was
crushing so i know i just have a bunch
of good scenes i just have to put this
thing together so i'm looking forward to
uh
to it so we wrap on tuesday and then i
have 10 weeks to get my first cut
to miramax which is uh
is exciting to just kind of go through
this whole process that i've never gone
through before
and put something together but i'm
actually really excited about the
editing
part of it
because
i learned so much working with mike
price at epis ephesfor family
that um
i hated it at first now i actually
really
enjoy
that process of like tightening each
time each pass tightening it up a little
bit more
and uh we got some really cool music for
the movie
um
but i am just going in there blind like
i've never done this before but you know
i got great people around me i'm not an
idiot i put great people around me that
are gonna help me through the process
and uh
i've already learned
so much
like the amount of movies i've been in
and i had no [ __ ] idea
it took me like 10 movies to be in to
just know to be able to look for the
sound card
i used to just walk up to people and i'd
be like asking an electrician where the
paint was
i just didn't know who to talk to about
what
and uh i think i was so busy trying not
to get fired
and now i understand
i can't say all of it but i understand a
lot more of it
um at least now i talk to the right
people
that's the questions
to the uh to the right people so anyway
um enjoy the basketball this weekend
uh
yeah
try not to let your emotions get the
best of you
[Laughter]
and if you do just try to apologize in a
sincere way
all right
um
that is it that is all
crazy week man [ __ ] is crazy man
i'm gonna try to do some stand up
tonight i'm open with that whoa what's
up with the world man [ __ ] is crazy all
right that's it uh enjoy the music
and there is a um
a bonus episode of the thursday
afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast following the
music
uh
picked out by the always wonderful
andrew themeless all right have a great
weekend you [ __ ]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
march 31st 2014
and i know you're bitching you're saying
this is late you're right it is late
i'll give it to you this week it is late
but that's only because
i'm doing a very special episode
of the monday morning podcast uh i
alluded
in past episodes that uh
about this tour that was coming together
with the guys that i go on the road with
uh paul verzi jason lawhead and joe
bartnick that possibly the three of them
were going to come together like one of
those superhero movies and do their own
[ __ ] tour and they are the all-in
tour and it starts tonight
at um at lago
at uh 7 30 tonight and uh right now uh
joe bartnick isn't here yet but uh
paul dude i called it verzi is here and
uh jason lawhead are both here so i want
to welcome both of you to the podcast oh
thanks man thanks for having us here at
your lovely uh studio oh thank you this
is uh this is this is the all things
comments it's late studios it's late
today what is the podcast you take i i
noticed though you take a wow
[Music]
what's the matter being knighted i
sounded weird there for a second yeah
but they can't hear it oh okay um
you take a lot of flack for that [ __ ]
for like if you're like a couple hours
late i noticed like you'll post your
thing and people will be where you go
billy red [ __ ] dick yeah you're an
[ __ ] it's what i i can't believe like
i'm like yeah but
i know this monday morning it's like two
in the afternoon
guys
it's
yeah it's what people do everybody's in
the bushes
so they can say whatever the [ __ ] they
want maybe just i don't read twitter
it's hilarious i don't know
i don't think they're really genuinely
mad i think they just want to like you
know yeah for them
people in general they're not big on
heckling during the show but afterwards
if you're standing out there whoring
yourself out that's when they they'll
come by and they'll be like oh you're
not as tall as i thought you were going
to be [ __ ] like that and i always i
always just give them you know you had
90 minutes to say that yeah yeah that's
your [ __ ] that's always good when that
woman's standing there too then they go
home they probably take it out on her
hate [ __ ] or something i like to feel
that i had i had something to do with
that but that's not why we're here today
no we're here to uh promote uh your guys
your guys tour and uh do you have any of
the dates here that i could actually
start reading okay
tonight
tonight it's already sold out um we are
going to go ahead and answer it we're
still waiting for bartnik bartnick yeah
answer it answer the phone
um all right by the way if you hear
weird noises out of jason lawhead he
[ __ ] his back up
yeah there you go all right so here we
go
the all things comedy tour starring paul
verzi jason lawhead and joe bartnick is
uh tonight it's at the uh largo in los
angeles which is already sold out and
tuesday april 1st tomorrow night if
you're down in
comedy starved san diego a lot of comics
never go down there they're going to be
at the mad house comedy club
tomorrow tuesday april 1st sunday april
6th they're going to be at parlor live
in bellevue washington
monday april 7th they're at helium
comedy club in portland oregon tuesday
april 8th san francisco uh they're going
to be at the punch line
wednesday april 9th they're going to be
at the punch line and thursday april
10th the punchline so 8th 9th and 10th
10th is in sacramento oh sacramento
sorry 8th and 9th in san francisco and
uh 10th and sacramento there you go
there you go and i'm excited because
i've never been to sacramento
i've never been anywhere
oh jesus what are we doing here i've
never been anywhere in california other
than long beach and l.a so i'm looking
forward to san diego tomorrow see this
is fun for me because you're in
california i've been out to see you in
new york at least a handful of times
since we've been friends but you've
never been to california all you know is
and alvarez he does his [ __ ] on
california yeah yeah
yeah
he got hammered when we were in this
cigar bar in calgary and i was [ __ ]
on the yankees no you were sitting on
golf i think i was [ __ ] on golf i
was like golf and then i cuz i was
saying that about playing it or
following like where i keep where i put
it as far as sports competition gotcha
and i put it in with bowling pool
shuffleboard where where it's one of
those things so he gets mad at me and he
starts going he starts going like you
know what billy goes i wish he goes
because burritos suck
like he comes at me with the cuisine he
goes all it is is beans and rice and i
go yeah paul that's all it is no one
ever thought to put anything else in
there uh yeah i got by but you know you
even said i got drunk you said it hit me
like it's like a smoke bomb like i that
time you started [ __ ] remember that time
you got hammered and you were just like
you were a mess
like let me get my calendar
but do you think do you think that's bad
though i saw you shaking your head that
that's where i i put golf i'm not saying
it's not anywhere near bowling or
shuffleboard the no no no i'm not saying
because there's all different degrees of
of of difficulty but i'm just saying as
far as you're playing a sport where it's
all between your ears
between your ears there's nobody
physically trying to stop you mother
nature it's it's all times oh give me a
[ __ ] i'm just saying when why i mean
there's a lot of forces
a guy hits a home brother like that
would have been out of here and it
wouldn't help no what i know but when
baseball players talk about how
difficult it is they talk about trying
to hit a curveball they don't talk about
the wind hey no forget mother hit the
golf ball sun's in your eyes forget
mother nature they're making skin cancer
yes
no
no but there's more than that it's not
even that it's how about the fact that
you actually do have to have a proper
swing posture your hips your legs your
hands you're not listening to me intact
too your body's not listening to me i'm
not saying it's not difficult
you golfing zombies what i'm saying is
is it's not [ __ ] playing football
basketball hockey where there's somebody
trying to stop you there's not a pitcher
throwing the [ __ ] golf ball 100 miles
an hour your chin to back you off the uh
the t and then you got to come up there
and settle back into your [ __ ] swing
right now okay that's all i'm saying i
know it's mentally difficult but it's in
the same family as pool
bowling shuffleboard horseshoes all the
way down to some of the most simplistic
sports there are tidally winks nobody's
stopping you
no i mean nobody's stopping in jacks
you don't need to be in shape to do
shuffleboard you don't need to be in
shape to bowl that's such a terrible
point to bring up with because i'll tell
you i'll [ __ ] show you dude first
time i watched the masters kenny perry
he looked like somebody's grandfather
[ __ ] came out and he blew he blew it
and then some other fat argentina guy
wanted they'll be fat oh cabrera that
guy's still i and i give i'll give i'll
concede that fat guys can play golf i
guess dude sweat
bill nicholson's man
but it's so unacceptable he should
always that's why they should have to
carry their own bags yeah but they're
not piles of [ __ ] kenny perry's not a
pile of [ __ ] dude what is it
honestly just just during what is he
closer to just during a sudden death
play-off he is oh
no no no
but what is he closer to is he closer to
an adonis or a tub of [ __ ] oh no yeah
he's he's definitely closer to a tub of
[ __ ] yeah and another tub of [ __ ] beat
him
to [ __ ] dude even that guy who bought
the general lee car he doesn't look like
he did a [ __ ] pull-up in his life he
had those seventh grade straight arms
where you don't have you just have
basically the humerus bone with a little
bit of meat hanging on it so you can
still pick up a pencil or a boat iron
the the guy the guy who hit that amazing
shot
and bubble watch oh bubba
right right i love that coarse
come on yeah he's like the guy that's
he's the jet skis he's totally the kenny
powers of
baseball so i'm not but i'm not
disrespecting the sport
i'm not disrespecting the sport but i'm
just saying the reason why i find the
sport
boring as hell
to play
is the fact that there's nobody guarding
me and i just get i get bored shitless
by three four [ __ ] holes i don't care
the whole thing is silly i'm trying to
put this little ball in a hole a hole is
unguarded there's nobody trying to swat
it away is it gold tending it's just
[ __ ] hole in the ground yeah but you
should have a good way to look at it
it's designed differently it's just a
different game listen there's a reason
why i should have been in caddyshack too
there's there's a reason why a bunch of
[ __ ] old people when they start
putting on weight
you know and they need to get active
they always pick up that sport and i'm
telling you those fat [ __ ] who if you
threw a baseball the the odds of them
chipping their tooth can somehow still
get on a golf course and i'm not saying
they crush it like a pro but they can
hit the [ __ ] thing straight enough
they're all right they're okay they're
okay they're not fun to play with they
can shoot a 105. i love how we're
calling millionaire golfers tubsy [ __ ]
yeah they're not fun
john daly used to be [ __ ] pounding
beers
john daley was an animal i heard his
book like he was an animal i used to we
used to go to the uh firestone every
year some buddies of mine down at the
nec in akron and we used to follow this
is back in the like late 90s mid to late
90s when daley was on top of the world
he was in every tournament because he
was you know he was still exempt from
all of his wins i love that guy too dude
he was the best we would follow him
around he bombed the ball past everybody
this is before tiger made a name for
himself on the tour and he was a smoking
ch he would chip jim
chainsmoke you know they don't show it
on tv but a lot of these guys chain
smoke it's like they hit the driver they
light the cigarette and he literally
changed when the camera goes away from
him when the camera goes away from him
he there they don't put the camera on
him and a lot of times when you do
they'll go back to be like we'll go to
daley at 16. he's got a cigarette
burning in the fairway you just don't
see it he takes his hit and they say and
then they show the ball you know he saw
it hit the green and they show him like
you know give his club and then once
they show like the trees and the
leaderboard he's back smoking yeah
he carries a he actually smokes so much
he's got an old coffee can with a hook
on the side of his bag when his when his
win
no does he yeah because they don't want
him littering up those nice courses
that's not cool so he his like you
literally you would follow him and his
caddy had put the bag down and he'd be
waiting to hit his approach in and he'd
be smoking cigarettes as long as he goes
and he'd throw it in the coffee can or
if he still had a cigarette with his
time to hit he'd throw it on the grass
and just let it burn wait to pick it up
it's hilarious well listen i know it's
difficult because i've actually talked
to a professional athlete hall of famer
who said those guys mentally are the
strongest athletes because you get all
that time to stand with the ball
thinking i understand that but there's
just something about the fact that
there's nobody trying to stop you but me
it's just
the the activity of it i feel like i
might as well just sit in a restaurant
with a chopstick trying to catch a fly
it's just like why am i doing this this
is just dumb
i'm not working up a sweat like i just
i would rather play [ __ ] horseshoes
and then just walk back over to the
grill
and just grab a sandwich like i just
understand what i'm doing part of it
might be because i'm so pasty and i'm
out there yeah you might like do you
know how bad i want to go out on the
course with you guys because you smoke
it oh that's just a guy
drinking but i'm just like i'll meet you
at the [ __ ] at the club yeah but the
drinking and the smoking on the course
is so fun oh this uh there's nothing
it's so fun cuban on a golf i know but
this is the thing maybe that's that's
how you have to sell the sport because
it's not like yeah you want to go play
hockey and just be like yeah you're
smoking stogies all right maybe i'll
come we should have like it's fun we
should have an annual like we'll call it
the cuban open we'll just get like like
four or eight guys get a couple
foursomes we meet at a golf course every
year we just absolutely we just play
like two rounds of golf over two days
and just smoke cubans and drink scotch i
gotta tell you this if i if i ever
became a president again if i ever if i
ever became president one of the first
things i would do
was and i would risk my own
assassination by doing this because i
would go against all the corporate [ __ ]
and i would basically i would break
bread
with castro and those guys and i would
just be like all right listen we were
wrong
to try and turn your island into a bunch
of starbucks and casinos
in the end of the day it is your
property do it with it what you want
we'll bring you some cars down here just
start sending us the cigars again
and we'll just leave it at that but
that's not they're actually waiting for
him to die
and then they're gonna turn that place
into uh
it's it's gonna look like orange county
it's gonna be [ __ ] brutal yep it's
terrible he you know i'm not saying the
guy's the greatest leader i'm not saying
i want to be underneath the guy but
in principle they were right it was
their country they had the right to do
okay we're going to take callers here
obviously game like a [ __ ] player
we're going to take god
i'm so [ __ ] sick
of having to try and fight it's kind of
the excitement of smoking a cuban is
trying to find one yeah you know and uh
now you know what everybody's gonna say
you know 90 of them are fakes
yeah where you go they are they're
already on twitter doing it probably
yeah they they do that [ __ ] but um but
even now like you know if you order them
and they send them in you know they get
a little hard well i'm just getting
tired of people talking about like how
it could get you sick and how it could
give you you know you know give your
throat cancer and [ __ ] it's like listen
man you know i'm not smoking these like
cigarettes like a package if i'm gonna
smoke one or two cigars a week that's it
that's it i think you smoked four in two
nights
and i don't even live in new york yeah i
mean that just happened i just happened
to be there yeah well you know no it was
like five it was it was it was it was a
yeah it was a couple of jerseys
your backpedal at night
there was a couple days
that does break down to 14 a week anyway
dude i love them i [ __ ] love them so
now i got to ask you guys now when you
go to go out on this tour
being the scotch drinking cigar smokers
that you are
uh what what is the what is the over
under on weight gained
on uh on this the all the uh the all-in
tour here well my my plan coming in and
i told i told my wife this my plan
coming in was to to not try to hang with
bartnik
like no no no i'm not even kidding like
bartnik is not like we're gonna need
bartnik to be a day behind the tour when
we're in portland he's gonna need to be
in seattle when we're in sacramento he's
gonna have to be in san francisco i've
never seen i'm not even kidding i'm not
even joking around i'm not just saying
this you know i've never seen a grown
man
endure
what he can do and still be able to
throw back to throw it like to hold it
together i mean that dude like he was
going back to the bar he's going yeah
man how about another heater and
remember i had to tell him like dude
listen i was at my wedding right yeah at
bill's wedding he goes hey dude you guys
law at first you want another heater and
i literally you did it yeah i go guys
i'm not gonna lie i can't do it like i
need i need a break here the party the
bartenders at the wedding we're
we're pulling bartenders over from other
bars to watch they were like
watch this guy watch watch what he does
the guy walking up now watch what he
does and the thing about your wedding
which was awesome was there was never
like it was never hard to get either a
hard liquor it was just always right
there and the guy knew what you wanted
so bartnik would go yeah you guys want
more heaters another round of heaters
they would just start giving them and
then bartnik's just drinking his crown
and i just patted him on the back and i
was like you are and he just had that
shitty grin but he was talking straight
all the way into the bar well he's for
people don't know him he's he's a
mountain of a man like he he could give
he's like cam neely's size man he's like
no he's he's a yeah yeah so we're all
like what like 5 10 or whatever trying
to keep up with a dude who's like 6'4
yeah i mean me and you by the end of the
night we were shot and he was just like
hey guys you want one of these for the
road he was like helping us he was like
gleason when he comes back against uh
you know uh fast eddie
in the hospital you know he's just
sitting there putting the carnation back
in his jacket let's play some pool
popping his stuff yeah well that's how
they that's funny is because like i
think over those heaters and all that
drinking is how we came kind of came up
with this idea for the tour yeah that
was that bill's wedding in october we'll
see we just started jumping about it
bill's not going to be to voice a reason
on this one he's kind of letting us go
bill's not gonna be around to go hey
guys that's a good sign you're in
trouble when i'm the voice of reason
yeah no but you many times how much do
you have to talk me into something no
that's the thing no you know what bill
does this is what he does he acts like
he's the guy like to like to keep it
cool yeah he'd be like yeah really i
should go oh this was so funny we're in
canada he goes listen man i'm not
drinking tonight i'm not drinking
tonight i swear to god i'm backstage
and he's on stage he's on stage and i'm
thinking i'm going back to the toys
again no not tonight not tonight he's on
stage asking the crowd you guys know
where we could let's just say we did
let's just say we were
to go out and then after after i get you
know to close out the show he'll be like
yeah we'll get one we'll get one so like
he acts like he's not gonna but see
bartnik is just like i mean every tweet
crowns crown like bartnik's in like he's
all in he's all in dude yeah that was
hilarious we were in buffalo one time he
pulled the same thing in buffalo it was
after a bruins playoff win we were in
but we were in buffalo doing buffalo
while the in june right and then we were
like talking it the whole time at the
the place like yeah you know i'm gonna
travel not gonna really drink tonight
we get back to the hotel he's like you
know that bruins game still on let's
just go down to that little like bar
like yeah
we watch it bruins win we celebrate
right there at the bartender we have one
we'll have one beer right we have one
beer at the bottom if bruins win we're
kind of celebrating the bartenders
bill goes hey if we weren't gonna go out
somewhere around here
next door next thing you know we're next
door getting hammered talking to these
locals eating bacon remember that bacon
they put bacon out as a bar snack
remember that's right so we had to do
this midwest man i know it's buffalo but
you're already north of pittsburgh yeah
they bring hot bacon out in baskets for
their bar snack and i'm like looking i
go bacon's not cheap man i i know food
like i asked the bar i'm like wait a
minute this is crazy she's like nah it's
friday and saturday nights only but it
gives people drink they they make the
bacon i asked the guy he came out they
make the bacon they let it cool for like
25 minutes so you don't burn yourself on
it so it's warm but not hot and it just
comes and you just eat it's amazing i
was like i'm not going to eat this and
then it's it's like literally like crack
you have a couple handfuls and then you
get then it's all salty and then you
want to start pounding yeah they were
setting this up
i got to do some ads here hang on a
second all right
all right here we go um
let's see if i can uh read these without
messing them up
all right dollar shave club everybody
nothing feels better
than that first shave with that with a
fresh blade right it's smooth it's close
and the blade is sharp and it's it's as
sharp as it's ever going to be it feels
fantastic
but thanks to the big shave company's
ridiculous prices you can't afford to
use a fresh blade every week can you see
you drag that dull ass blade across your
face for two three weeks 10 weeks why do
you do it to yourself maybe because the
only thing more painful than shaving
with an old blade is shelling out 30
bucks for a pack of new ones well if you
want to enjoy the fresh if you want to
enjoy a fresh blade every week but you
don't want to go out
and take out another mortgage on your
house you got to join
dollarshaveclub.com
for just a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com ships the highest
quality blades you can get
um
and there's that stuff where i'm
supposed to act like i'm a four blade
guy i like the three blade guy um
seriously only six bucks for the best
quality blades you can get so every week
you can pop in a fresh blade and treat
yourself to an amazing shave it's
incredible
um join dollarshaveclub.com get amazing
quality blades in the mail for a couple
of bucks and treat yourself to a brand
new blade every single weeks hundreds of
thousands of guys
um jesus i suck this week
hundreds of thousands of guys with their
up
with have upgraded see this isn't me
this is the copy hundreds of thousands
of guys have upgraded
uh they're shaving with dollar shave
club i'm one of them and i'm loving it
now it's your turn
shavetimeshapemoneydollarshaveclub.com
that's dollarshaveclub.com
all right one more here stamps.com
everybody the classic i know it's a
tough i know it's tough deciding where
to focus your resources to grow your
business well isn't it uh but one thing
i can tell you you don't need to waste
valuable time going to the post office
for mailing and shipping anymore why you
ask well i'll tell you why just use
stamps.com to ask access all the
services of the post office right from
your desk 24 7 with stamps.com
buy and print official us postage using
your own computer and printer get post
office uh get postage for any letter or
package any class of mail all for just a
fraction of the cost of an expense of a
postage meter with stamps.com you'll
never have to go to the post office
again so you can spend your time where
it matters most focused on your business
or other areas of your body i use
stamps.com right now use your last name
bill burr what right now use my last
name burr for this special offer no risk
trial
plus 110 bonus offer includes a digital
scale and up to 55 postage don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burr burr
that stamps dot com enter burr
oh i'll tell you that was a rough one
you know
that was a rough one yeah kenny parrot
that one
that was terrible no but then you guys
were moving in the background and then
when you guys started talking about you
know what you know what it's not okay
let me finish bill that's not let me
finish that
off
that's what happened no no that's also
basketball it's every other [ __ ]
sport if you're trying to take a foul
shot
no what it was was i started thinking
like this is how uninterested people are
at home listening to this [ __ ]
like the fact that you guys i love you
my favorite part is like when i watch
i've been watching every dribble of
march madness because i've been having
this bad back like i literally have seen
like more traveling calls than a refs
have but the thing is
i've been sitting there whole time and i
love like vern lundqvist is the best
because you know we talked about like
dialing stuff in like that guy like when
he's doing the or not yeah he's been
broadcasting for 100 years but he has to
do those live spots for like 60 minutes
you know he's like well 12 18 to go in
kentucky's right back it is on this one
coming up tonight
16 minutes don't forget to catch the
pink panthers do we get the jewel
thieves or don't we tonight in 60
minutes and you're like the horny hates
that i love it you just totally hate you
compared reading ads on a podcast that's
golf that's how tough cup is
right there no there you go there's your
point made
[Laughter]
how i met you [ __ ]
out on the road
the fact that i would loan the monday
morning podcast presents the all things
uh comedy tour for some reason you can't
be late to this thing because you
downloaded it but if you're playing this
and your wife is walking around the
background or husband uh once again the
all things comedy tour is coming to san
diego tuesday april 1st uh it's going to
be in bellevue washington sunday april 6
at parlor live
uh helium comedy club portland oregon
and then two nights at san and uh at the
punch line in san francisco the eighth
and ninth in sacramento on the 10th um
yeah then we're going to swing it over
to the east coast in a couple months
more dates to follow i think they're
working on that but i'm looking forward
to doing these coast states are coming
in the end of may billy boston but we're
doing that
all these guys all these guys open for
me if you've come out and uh seen any of
my shows basically in the last [ __ ] i
don't know five six years it's been one
of these guys opening for me so i'm
excited for you guys i was actually
trying to think who i met first i think
i met you lawhead yeah we've been on
each other for a long time
it's coming up on 10 years no it's over
10 years you know what's funny is i
didn't want to get i didn't want to get
like sentimental about it
because
you know you drank
whiskey but no like we did that show we
did that show on new year's eve we did
that show on new year's eve at the will
turn
and that was literally 10 years to the
day we met we like hung out on new
year's day new year's day 10 years like
new year's eve you did cleveland and
then hung out we and then that's when we
that's when we became friends is like
you just came and hung out with me on
new year's day because you had nothing
to do you we were dark but you had to
stay in cleveland for like two more
nights oh yeah this was a deal like new
year's eve was a uh was like a thursday
yeah there was a wednesday or thursday
so then there was new year's day and
nobody's coming out that day but then
there was you still had the weekend so i
had this weird weekend there where i was
working new year's i was doing a run the
whole week doing new years and i had a
day off
so i had a day off and uh nick the club
owner the greatest guy ever at uh
hilarity's out there in cleveland he
goes you know just just watch out for
the guy you know keep him company bubba
dude we [ __ ] drank
all day they actually lost me at one
point we somehow ended up in this brutal
titty bar yeah brutal the silver horse
silver horse
and uh yeah that's how boring cleveland
is you need like the comic needs to be
assigned somebody to just
that's that's how it was yeah i was like
that guy i was like hey jason what are
you doing no well entertain this guy
please cleveland is way better than even
it was like 10 years ago i was just
there recently
what's your own face yeah like and i
dude i wish i had money back then
because i was like i'm
like i'm gonna buy a freaking building
because you could see it coming it's
coming back around unlike detroit which
keeps starting and stopping cleveland
you could buy a hospital for like 80
grand in cleveland yeah
they showed up they showed
out there i'm closing on a hospital you
could
you could get like a four bedroom house
there for like thirty six thousand
dollars it's insane but i gotta tell you
though but like when when i first played
hilarities in cleveland that was the
only game in town on that street you
walked like you walked up that street
like a cop
i crossed the street out of my hotel so
the cop met you at the corner and walked
you up the street and now it's like
closed off to traffic they got the house
of blues across the street they got all
this stuff going on restaurants and
stuff i remember seeing this giant
apartment building like right across the
way i think mike was living there at the
time yeah around the corner and i was
thinking like like i was literally
thinking that i go i bet you could buy
that thing for 75 grand and in 20 years
it's gonna be worth like millions of
dollars as this whole thing eventually
hopefully comes back
yo you know they got the casino they
just built another casino like not
downtown but somewhere else but um ah
that's not a good idea i don't like that
i don't like that idea i just don't like
the casino idea i think that we could
have built that that there's no reason
that that city can't be built on its
waterfront and its character and its
position geographically in the country
through casinos then it's like casino
it's like nightlife for like toddlers
the nice thing about
to dc we're close to new york there's no
reason we could we can't be successful
you know it's funny though the nice
thing was i said to uh you know beau the
the guy i love i said i said he loves
you he loves your parents and stuff but
i said i go i go bow how come to you
know where's the hulk because homeless
is big out there big big like they come
after you and i go how come there's it's
light on the homeless and he goes
they're all at the casino
it's just like all right yeah is that
right yeah they're just all hanging out
at the world playing nickel slots all
day long that was like the lottery for
that that's that was the lottery then
you're bringing in they started
stretching it
started stretching when that place yeah
right
why would homeless people go to a casino
they don't have any [ __ ] money what
are they doing there
they whatever they make though some of
those people make decent money that's
amazing i love that theory
some of those guys yeah they make like a
hundred grand some of them do no i don't
know about 100 grand a year but some of
them are still sitting their own urine
in that [ __ ] cardboard box let me
talk about committed
what's that [ __ ] when your feet uh
frostbite yeah with black toes making
100 grand a year you know yeah
nfl guys smash their brains around the
homeless they lose their toes do that
scam in south beach coal miners black
lung you get a black foot dude i gotta
tell you when i was in san francisco uh
i was just up there trying to find some
place where i could shoot my special and
and dude i i have never seen
so many people laying around not doing
[ __ ]
in that city i don't know where
everywhere well they used to have a
stipend they used to [ __ ] give them
money was this was hilarious again the
homeless man they would give them enough
money to get to try to get them off the
street it was one of those things where
it made sense if you were giving it to
people who thought sensibly but they
didn't they gave it to the [ __ ]
homeless so they would give you enough
money so you could afford rent in some
flop house for a month so what would
happen is the first four days
of the month you wouldn't see any
homeless people they were all inside
drinking and shooting and drugs and all
that [ __ ] with the money they'd have
enough money for four days and then by
the fifth day they'd start coming out
like zombies and then you had the
problem again so they would basically
were buying themselves like a four or
five day reprieve now of course as
always with all my stories that's just
something
that like four four or five people did
tell me that story in san francisco i
don't know if it's true but i was there
and they had um
they all the all these beautiful parks
and dude these people are snoozing
to a level you actually start thinking
like what am i working for like look at
that dude i saw this guy like he was
like face down in the sun like some like
old hound dog
and i was really just thinking like this
[ __ ] guy like i know he's living
outside but he's eating
yeah you know he doesn't have any
confidence calls there's no
debt doesn't wake him up
this guy dude it was such a beautiful
sunny day it was one of those days where
you actually would entertain the thought
that i could like
i could just [ __ ] live outside this
is beautiful
dude i took a picture of the guy and i i
tweeted it and what was funny is i
didn't even realize that there was
another guy in the background it's like
you can't just get one there's so many
of them when you get to the parks just
[ __ ] lying all over the place
um i saw when i was just there doing
cobs a couple weeks ago and i saw a guy
laying on a park bench sleeping covered
up a champagne bottle at his at his feet
right cop strolling i was sitting in
another park bench just people watching
this guy's hilarious he just bundled up
not only am i watching this guy he's got
the champagne bottle i have pulled his
feet two cops come strolling up towards
him they're like hey got it let's go
pick it up let's go and one guy picks up
and he like wakes up out of a panic and
he sees the one cop holding his half
empty bottle and he's getting ready to
go pour it out and he's like panicking
like hey
somebody that's not my wine it's not my
wife the guy doesn't care he knows he's
like yeah i'm sure it's not he's like
pouring it out right the funniest thing
is is this guy when he got up and he ran
along and i noticed it after he woke up
he put it up there he had american
airlines eye
the patches to cover your eyes so smell
the sleep mask
you got an american airlines logo flimsy
little one that they probably give you
on the flight and they were like so then
they were up on his forehead as he was
like begging for like mercy oh wait
these goblins i'm looking at them going
wait a minute what are you worried about
anyway
them putting you under a roof like a
roof what are you worried about yeah but
dude i would rather sleep outside and
worry about getting hit over the hill
with a log and [ __ ] take one of my
ass yeah
you know
yeah hey you know i heard that there's
like a bed they actually uh
they actually uh and one of those cities
when they had like the stipend other
cities were flying their [ __ ]
homeless people in there
to just get rid of them because they
were having and then they started
sending them back i forget what the [ __ ]
happened maybe that's where that guy got
the mask i can't remember i can't
remember what it would be hilarious if
that's where he got the mask he still
had it that's what i'm guessing the
other night in new york i saw a lot of
the homeless they sleep on the top step
of the church but the church never lets
them in
so like they're just laying there like
would you what no i no i know but it's
just like but after a while they got to
be like listen they're not listening
they're not opening up let's go
somewhere else yeah you know what i mean
yeah like they're just laying on the
thing and it's almost like sad because
it's almost like they have the belief
and the faith and they're being shut out
well i think that the church i'd be like
[ __ ] it dude i'm going to starbucks i'm
going somewhere else because no one
someone's not listening right you know
it's just yeah i'm showing my faith no
but
it's good business for them to let them
stay there like they give a [ __ ] but
they're not going to let them in
um
but i don't know if that seems like a
safe place you want a safe place to
sleep if you're home i don't have any
homelessness just let them sleep on the
church floor
because i don't want it
there the saddest part about how this
conversation got steered into is we were
talking about cleveland
that's the saddest part of it all right
we've just gone to the dregs of humanity
how'd the atomic start cleveland but
anyway um
no but i find that interesting when i
kept seeing well you don't want a bunch
of smelly homeless people stinking up
the church for the decent people who
come in on sundays and that might sound
like fox news but at the end of the day
if you smell like urine you smell like
urine you got to go outside but what if
dogs what if the dude doesn't smell and
he's just freezing you know put him in
one of the pews and let him you know
[ __ ] let him sleep in your baby start
smelling when he thaws up i didn't say i
didn't say i'm gonna let him see my but
he smells good though paul yeah he just
got some uh i don't know him he's a
stranger there's a church he's gonna go
in there and steal all the chalices that
they stole from the other [ __ ] people
i just feel like if he's saying that
he's got faith in that church they
should do something that's all that's
what church should be that's what it's
about right right right should be here
listen faith costs money baby put a
little in the bank exactly but that's my
point that's my point
what is your point paul my point is that
like they trying to get steep on us here
no no no i'm just saying like you know
uh
you know you know
no what i'm saying is i i
i see them laying on the front step of
the churches and it's kind of a sad
thing to see because they're wrapped up
in their blankets and they have so much
faith in that belief yet the doors are
never opening and it was just a an
observation that i found [ __ ] up why
do you think that the fact that they're
sleeping on the stairs means they
believe in jesus christ i'm not saying
that they i'm just saying that it's just
i i think the people that choose whose
thing is unraveling no i think that i
think the fact that these people choose
to be on the on the top step at the door
of a church tells me that they have some
sort of faith because i think
what if it rains you want to be
underneath the yard but there's a
million you could go under you know
awnings of places or you could go under
you know buildings
yeah it doesn't mean you believe in
burger king but you know what the church
that i saw this guy on there was no roof
he was just sleeping there man so i just
put i just stopped
i i don't think he believes in it okay i
don't think he does because you know him
no but you don't know him either no i
don't but i think it's he could or he
might not just because you're sleeping
on church stairs doesn't mean you
[ __ ] believe in anything wouldn't you
think it's a good guess to think that
he's got some sort of faith if that's
his choice of i would think it would be
safer to sleep there than outside a
white castle this is the first dude
you've called it on a homeless
where the [ __ ] is bartnik
he ain't making it
yeah that's bartnik right there
[Music]
he ain't going to make it so i think
he's going to make it this is this
dedication this is the dedication we're
going to have with this [ __ ] tour is
that what we're saying here um
no but going back to that wait no let's
start some more arguments here hey so
you're a cleveland indian man i'm a red
sox fan he's a yankees fan the old
american league east the old american
league east now right
yeah
what how do you feel about uh both of
our teams and the way we spend money
each year i think it's disgusting now i
will say that uh boston last year wanted
in a way where they didn't go out and
over like they didn't spend any more
than they kind of had been spending
uh i love the fact that most of the
most of the trend is all these teams
that are spending money aren't really
the teams that are being successful at
the end of the day
you can finally say that see
i loved it no not because of that i just
love the fact that like the dodgers are
trying to you know the dodgers are going
all in well they have all of them they
have to
all into it but you know but that's what
you know what you're saying because
they've been they've been they've been
25 years without a championship
um they've corrected their financial
situation after the guy in magix knew
you know um what i forget the guy's name
that ran him into the group spending 230
million dollars is the way well you know
they didn't set the trend i i i got to
believe that if they believe that
they're going to do something that the
yankees of boston have done which they
haven't done yet in this in this
economics of baseball yeah you got to do
it i mean the last time they
they won was in 88 when the economics
were shifting a little but it wasn't
it's it wasn't a five
mega uh market league
being able to spend that kind of there's
only five teams that can spend that kind
of there's only five teams that can
spend that kind of money so why wouldn't
they if they're one of the five teams i
can spend let me ask you a question why
do you think that baseball allowed
it to to go the direction what was the
what was the thinking that it was good
to let [ __ ] the yankees do what they
did which caused the red sox to have to
react to it and then we became them
i mean we're not right now i don't think
but but we in oh seven i mean there's no
[ __ ] there's no there's nobody on the
planet they can't tell me in 07 we
didn't buy a [ __ ] title
well i think it all stems back a lot of
it stems back from obviously you can't
change what happens money-wise but i
think a lot of it sends back to when the
um owners were
you know uh found out about the
collusion in in the late 80s and they
had to pay once they paid the once they
played the players union i think 350
million dollar settlement for collusion
and the players which was basically what
owners getting together going down they
said don't pay jack morris is what i was
jack morris was on the free agent market
i think in 86 or 87 and the tigers owner
told all the other owners don't pay him
keep them at the market value that we
have and it all
in the long run yeah we got to keep jack
morris but in the long run all you guys
will be able to keep your kirby pockets
and your roger clemens is at a price
that won't gouge us that was fine blah
blah blah the end of the day is it
strengthened the players union to a
point where
the salaries have gotten to the point
that the players union
really runs the market
and they run the market so now the big
market teams that have the money
they've opened the players unions have
has made it able to be able to sp for
those teams to spend that money and the
rich teams can well that's that's the
bottom line the bottom line is as long
as there's no cap in baseball
eighty percent of the teams will never
win a world series and no it says as
long as there's no cap the the kansas
city royals are never gonna i don't know
if it's that high but i mean it's gonna
be at least 60. close the one thing is
is what baseball's tried to do is
obviously with the wild card and now the
extra wild card right so we tried to
make it somewhat competable whereas a
team like cleveland or minnesota if by
the all-star break if we look like we're
playing really well with the guys we've
groomed in we can go out and
you know get a if the philadelphia
phillies are falling flat on their face
we can go out and get a jimmy rollins if
he doesn't if he wants to wave his trade
claws and be like you know what i want
to go play for these guys they're pretty
good i'm at a certain point in my career
go hit you know win a title whatever
that's the only thing baseball's done to
kind of recoup that but
don't look at the nfl and be like okay
the way they're doing it green bay can
compete with new york city can milwaukee
compete with boston no but brewers
compete with the red sox they can't so
what the players
why don't we do and and and why should i
be so strong because they can get big
players and you get the guys paid so do
you think there's another lockout coming
we'll talk and lock out here on the
podcast um i like talking to stuff i i
don't i don't see it looming anytime
soon i think baseball's in probably a
pretty pretty good
labor uh
labor situation because now the
players have had to kind of
crawl with their tails between their
legs a little bit in the last few years
with the with the peds and everything
else so they've kind of had to kind of
come off their high horse a bit so now
there's a little bit of love but there's
a little bit of balance between players
and owners because the players have kind
of had to go yeah yeah we were doing all
this [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] up that those
guys actually went in front of like the
senate or whatever the [ __ ] was going on
i don't understand i just don't get why
politics had to get involved why am i
watching kurt schilling
talking to some representative from
minnesota yeah because it's just [ __ ]
all stupid he should be talking to his
account
hey speaking of all the sections this
ties in with a question here that uh
somebody said i said bill what team
dear billy bats if you could coach one
team in history without knowing the
outcome of the season
which team would you pick keep in mind
stack teams don't always win
championships and there are other teams
that you that could have won perhaps
with some better coaching
what the [ __ ] that was like a brain
twister like a trains going this way if
i could coach one team in history
without knowing the outcome of the
season which would i pick keep in mind
stack teams don't always win
championships yeah but the teams won the
championship i know if i coached the
cowboys
in 78 they won the they beat the broncos
i don't get your question i'll just drop
that part of it but what team would you
coach because that is an interesting
question like if you could coach one
team no i think the question is saying
now
like i think the question is basically
like what you see now if you could coach
one of these teams that's out there now
and don't go out and try to win a
championship don't look who stacked but
just say who would you want to debbie
says one team in history oh okay all
right then look this guy is either
really smart and we're dumb or this is a
[ __ ] confusion question
uh
i don't [ __ ] know if i could coach
one team how about can i play on the
team instead
look i'd like to i'll go i'll go every
era
in in hockey if i could play on any team
i would play for the the the 80s
edmonton oilers
um
if i could play if i could i guess coach
dude you're a coach's son who would you
coach
if i could coach one team one time
uh i would probably
i would probably coach
larry bird 79 indiana state team against
magic i'd like to i'd like to coach that
game i'd like to see if we could if i
could help you i'd like to see if i
could beat magic maybe that's his
question
you know what i'd like to do i'd like to
coach the [ __ ]
uh 79 dallas cowboys and the 76 dallas
cowboys against the steelers in both and
i and i would win the [ __ ] game yeah
that's how confident i am because they
had their number in the first half oh
this is why we need bartnik dude if you
i watched somebody somebody put up the
70s super bowl 10 they put that up on on
the internet dude the cowboys called a
reverse on the first play reverse to
hollywood henderson he ran down the
field their kicker tackled him he took a
knee to the ribs [ __ ] up three of his
field goals and they were playing loose
and all that and they were up and then
they played mardi ball in the second
half and they got all [ __ ] tight and
they just they basically conserved the
game away
um as far as the uh
the 79 oh i guess i wouldn't know this i
wouldn't throw it to [ __ ] uh jackie
slater whatever the hell his name was
yeah jack smith
bless his heart he's the sickest man in
america i would coach did you see they
out loud the dunk
you know they made that a penalty now
the dunk of over the goal post and you
were saying hollywood henderson
hollywood henderson invented the dunk of
the goal post they we just had a baby
first one
they had a big thing on espn yeah the
owners meeting over the winner it's a
15-yard penalty now if you dunk the ball
because joey graham and all these guys
it's a you know they dated it back to
history they're like who the first man
and it was hollywood henderson after a
reverse landry used to call it reverse
all the time to hollywood henderson and
it was uh in 75 they called a reverse to
hollywood henderson in a regular season
game and he busted one loose for a
touchdown and he was the first guy and
they show it he's the first guy to go up
and dunk it over the goal post and why
did they outlaw that because he's
they're tearing down they're tearing
down some goal posts uh guys have gotten
hurt i guess i don't know well
one time joey graham from the saints was
so strong he pulled one down where they
had to come out and re-level the goal
post because it wasn't
you know so he pulled it and then the
next guy that kicks in it is kicking in
not a lot of white guys upset
about that rule wes welcome
[Music]
he needs to be on joey jimmy graham's
shoulders to talk this is a deal i would
i would i would actually if i could
coach any team in history what i would
probably do
is i would maybe the 86 red sox yeah but
no but then i but then i put dave
stapleton in at first yeah but that's
only because i know
yeah no what was going to happen so i
like i couldn't know so like uh i would
i would try to pick a team that that
hasn't won a championship but i live in
boston and they just won't run the table
so i don't know what to do for me it's a
no-brainer i would 100 coach the knicks
and i would i would make them run listen
i would make that run
i would make them run until they puked
i would i if they didn't play defense
they're out they're fined i would
[ __ ] go
with this team quit on i know exactly
you'd be the second you'd be the second
nick coach in history to get choked i
would
i would [ __ ] i'd lay into those lazy
[ __ ] suckers like i like i swear to god
dude that would be fun actually i would
like to just take a horrible team and
just be terrible you [ __ ] dice
minimum of three passes minimum of three
passes okay you [ __ ] are gonna run
all day we're not we're practicing the
first month without a ball you are
running up and down carmelo anthony's do
you you think you can do this with pros
or they're off carmelo anthony's
lazy weed face would [ __ ] get carmelo
you want to wear that headband go take
it off the top of the backboard yeah i
and i thought i said i couldn't be here
until two no it's all
i don't think anyone's missing my
my uh hey that we're currently answering
a question right now if you if you oh
this would be perfect for you you could
coach any team in history not knowing
the outcome if you could just be the
head coach who would you want to be head
coach of oh the steelers 78 steelers 78
i want to do the 78 cowboys or 76
cowboys
76. you have to just
83 sixers yeah i was thinking of them
too i said sixers
i said that they played four on five
they just played ivor
i mean they played four on five they
beat the beach anyway yeah i put them up
against i put them up against the 96
bulls yeah we talked about that on mine
and everybody goes who's going to stop
jordan i'm like well i think dr jay
could kind of offset a lot of the [ __ ]
he was doing and then i got moses
against the [ __ ] luke longley yeah i
don't think anybody's beating the 96
bulls that's because you're a child of
the 90s
dude that team i said
79 indiana state they were as good
defensively as they were trying to be
that's a good point that's a good one
but i'm telling you i don't know but
luke longley would have four fouls by by
the end of the first quarter trying to
stop moses malone yeah and
and in all fairness i didn't see enough
of that 76-15 but that how good was
pippin on defense i mean that defense
defensively they're right they're
there's a reason i picked the 96 bulls
well andrew tony had bad feet or andrew
tony would be in the hall of fame yeah
absolutely andrew tony could stroke they
didn't have six pointers back then six
year career yeah he could stroke him
yeah that was great he could stroke him
i mean that that that that was the
ultimate two-man game if you you had to
double team eminem yeah moses mounted
your mouth
he
he went from high school to dominating
the dominating aba the aba was like a
[ __ ] prison rec league yeah it was
did that mean
he was dumb people were afraid of moses
maloney like he was 17. yeah he was a
baby he was
that's back in the matter expection a
man child
it was like him daryl dawkins he never
lived up to the first guy joe was he the
first guy to come out yeah that early
yeah bows as well daryl dawkins was
second yeah you know the funny thing is
is
moses malone and lebron james are the
only two guys in the history of the nba
to win consecutive mvp awards with
different teams and they're the and they
and they both never played college ball
it's pretty freaking impressive yeah wow
i mean if you take out the big three you
know the the you know the the amount
right you know wilt kareem and uh
and bill russell and the next i mean
it's supposed to be mostly always the
beast
what did they lose that year they lost
one play on that's a high school kid
that's a baby
they lost one playoff game they actually
asked moses to predict that's his famous
thing he goes what do you think about
the playoffs he just goes
just mean we're going to sweep everybody
and they basically they lost one to the
lakers it was threefold
because back then it was a first round
game was a five but his question was
okay but the funny thing was is that i
was a huge sixer fan huge six feet back
in because i was a huge doctor fan huge
sixer fan and when he got traded because
you couldn't they they could never win
because caldwell jones and dawkins and
whatever and steve mix whatever
examination of [ __ ] that they put
together to stop either like parish or
jabar would never work so when they got
him he was having to cover a rock he was
like sitting on the steps like rocky it
was like you knew it was over there was
never a lock in the history of sports
like moses going to the sixers like you
knew it was over it was it was yeah how
come they only won one though because dr
j was old moses wouldn't know i mean he
wasn't old but he was he was dude moses
bat played back in the day where that
dude played 46 minutes a night dragging
dudes up and down that's why i say like
because because of black monday is why
they definitely won one black monday he
trade black
the only time i ever cried in sports
other than like lemieux getting cancer
they were crying sports black monday
dude they traded brad they they trained
dude they tried moses malone and the
rights to brad doherty for roy henson
and ruland dude they traded they are
brad he's doing nascar
but they traded like they their front
line would have been barkley bread and
bread dougherty and
moses said i will never lose to the
76ers again dude the bullets won like
eight games that year like five of them
were against the sixes
he was like 30 and 25 again brad
daugherty has probably the the most epic
[ __ ] hairline it's crazy it almost
touches his eyebrows i mean the [ __ ]
guy when he gets his shape up i mean
they got to like put a separator at the
grocery store between his eyebrows and
his it's just something sad about seeing
brad daugherty talk nascar
you know he's just sitting there talking
nasty it was even sadder we seen him sit
on the bench at all-star games i was
going to say
this in the shack i drafted it was like
well they're good
how did he get how did he [ __ ] go
from
he's like he's like one of the
announcers from nascar mountain north
carolina and he grew up in that [ __ ] and
uh he loves it he's always loved it well
that's all right then he ended up doing
something guys i got to read a couple of
the last [ __ ]
my last three brutal reads of this week
this this is this is not a vernon i'm
not not on my my game here this week i'm
gonna try to focus all right this is
just like golfing
um all right e-voice everybody um what
your business what your business want
your business dude i [ __ ] up the first
word e-voice everybody want your
business to make more money evoice can
help here's how when your customers call
you'll have your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by name
directory and more you'll sound like a
fortune 500 company and really stand out
from your competitors e-voice let you
give one number that rings wherever you
are you could be at your kids soccer
game you'll never miss a chance to grow
your business evoice takes all your
voicemail calls transcribes them and
sends them to you instantly as a text or
an email
email so you can check your voicemails
before the meeting ends and not look
rude rude e-voice is only 13 bucks a
month and right now my listeners get to
try e-voice free for 60 days that's
right a 60-day free trial don't put this
off turn down the radio get a computer
and set up your e-voice 60-day free
trial now so you can see what i mean go
to evoice.com promo code bill that's
evoice.com promo code bill
all right the next one legalzoom
everybody if the excitement of starting
your business uh getting your first
customer and finally quitting your job
hasn't moved you to action yet here's
another great reason to get started it's
not started it's national start your
business month at
legalzoom.com and they want to help you
start your own business or corporation
or llc or file a dba so you can get up
and running quickly and easily find out
why more than one million entrepreneurs
use legalzoom to start down the path of
successful business ownership this month
only take advantage of their national
start your business month special and
get a free three-month trial
of all new quickbooks making it so much
easier to run your new business uh
that's 119 value for absolutely free
when you enter bur in the referral box
checkout uh that's legalzoom.com promo
called burr legalzoom.com promo code
burr all right there we go i'll save the
other one till the end
um so anyways joe bartnick you excited
for the all things uh comedy uh tour
here all in tour it's gonna be epic it's
gonna be epic it's gonna be epic look at
this his game plan is uh he's gonna try
to avoid you as far as like his drinking
he's gonna try to like he's gonna try to
are you not drinking either no they i'm
drinking no no they're you you're
drinking no no we were talking about we
were telling you you know what the point
exactly that's exactly why he just
pointed at you like he was an nfl coach
and you were a defensive player who
missed an assignment
um i i'm drinking but he said like we
were talking about smoking cigars and
drinking and
bill said what's your game plan to not
you know to not gain so much weight and
go nuts and i go listen i go i got to
really just watch
bartnik because bartnik is you know you
you got that thing dude you're
unstoppable
you're [ __ ] unstoppable the thing is
you're like an idiot every year at the
rose bowl i try to go blow for blow
i don't
you were like you guys want another
heater and like after the fifth time i
was like joe man you know we just met i
was like i love i need i can't right now
like i i need a break at the end of the
night you had those crowns the shots and
you're smoking a cigar and you're just
intact
you were just [ __ ] intact it was just
the way it was it's the way we grow them
in pittsburgh i was i was back home this
weekend
i told people i said i know people in
hollywood like i think i got to go to
rehab i'm like first of all you drink
wine
i said second of all my aunts drink more
than you
before dinner
i mean people don't think it's just food
it's drink i mean come i mean but no
there's hey there's never peer pressure
because there's more boost for me no
don't get me wrong
i'm trying to run out some of these
times they stop early so we gotta keep
that in mind no no i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna definitely have some yeah but
[Laughter]
i think it's going to be an amazing tour
if you guys these guys are like they're
guys guys they're [ __ ] hilarious they
know smarts
and you know it's not gonna be uh
trust me you you it's definitely worth
the money as i mentioned earlier we're
gonna have all the dates up here uh
they're playing san diego uh bellevue
washington portland oregon uh san
francisco twice in sacramento so far and
then they got an east coast thing lineup
i'm really psyched for you guys that's
the midwest shows i got people in uh and
i want to thank everyone that came to
the shows this week in pittsburgh they
were awesome
we're we're coming back is the tour nice
nice they're stoked for us and the dve
guys are stoked for us to come and thank
you guys yeah if you guys met out you
got met uh
i told them i told them all about you
they're gonna and that's awesome yeah
they're gonna go they're gonna make fun
of me is what they're gonna do no we no
we feel your pain no you don't we feel
your feelings what do you feel you don't
feel like you're a sick super bowl
championship oh this is the cleveland
pittsburgh rivalry there's no there is
no rivalry there is no rivalry
there is no rivalry we don't we can't
you can't be
your browns rivalry is now the ravens
that we don't even have a rivalry with
you because we haven't put up a fight in
15 years i mean it's not it's true it
doesn't exist you think that there's
people that on the outside looking in
that remember that old brown steelers
that doesn't exist you go to cleveland
for brown steelers games it's a sea of
black there's no browns fans there they
sell their tickets of pittsburgh fans
there is no rivalry you can't be rival i
remember what was he the saddest moment
one of the saddest moments in la head's
adult life we're watching a steeler game
in a bar in san francisco he was up
there hanging out we're done doing shows
he did some sets
walk in the boot we look over the booth
next to us
a guy grew up right next door to him
yeah like four houses down four houses
down and haven't said he's cheering for
the steelers and he goes he's like what
are you doing because i just gave up i
wanted to back a winner
we see this kid in a booth next to me he
grew up four houses down for me i'm like
holy crap he's wearing a st he's on it's
a sunday football all the different
people are in there watching different
teams right and like he's like
he's wearing like a cordell stuart shirt
i went oh my god and he just said he
goes ah you know what i just gave up a
long time ago i said are you wearing a
steel are you rooting for the steelers i
know that this is the thing i understand
just saying [ __ ] it
i i'm not watching it anymore and then
then go
go to a different conference exactly
i wouldn't even root for anybody in the
afc exactly i would i would i mean if i
could if i would root for any i've i've
contemplated it and everybody has that
there but my contemplations are i would
go and i know you hate them but they're
central to me and i like the new young
quarterback
if i had to quit which i've thought of
i'm thinking of quitting and going to
indy
i don't mind andy right well i mean
i i like luck they're close by they're a
small little town
they've done everything right
i i'm thinking
well whatever i've talked about
that's a pluses
right exactly
no i'm saying their owner does drugs
sits on the rules committee he changes
rules of passing to help i don't see how
anybody could do it i think i'm just
saying that's like a knicks fan becoming
a [ __ ] brooklyn nets fan it's
despicable man it can't it can't do it
i'm just saying if i thought about it if
i agree with you just stop watching it
just stop watching and give up but you
can't just automatically take your job
because i go buy it go to the store and
buy another [ __ ] jersey then what
happens when your team actually [ __ ]
wins it yeah then you're an idiot then
you deserve it yeah you deserve your
team to win it a couple years ago that's
not gonna actually happen no
it has to happen eventually listen hey
listen
we're gonna we're gonna do i'm gonna
guarantee we win it this year it opens
on two days okay
dude that's the guy that rats out it's a
movie called draft day it opens i'm sure
something good is going to come out
that's a guy that rats out his friends
if you do that if you do that if you
switch uniforms because they're not
winning you're a rat you're right it's
definitely it's a character
wall street no no you're you'll rat your
friends out you can't trust that guy
you're gonna trust that guy no you can't
trust that phone no exactly guy's been
going to going to a stadium with his
mother and father as a kid and then he
just [ __ ] throws in the towel and
throws on the enemy shirt that kid will
sell you down a [ __ ] yeah the enemy's
shirt is that's that's that's dad that's
that's a character that is a character
that's a character flaw something's
wrong no you're right and i think he and
that person specifically i'm not going
to name names you know yeah i need to
join puck off today i need you a pug up
there's a lot of bruins stuff going on
speed my man crush
what was did you see what he did what
did he do
dude
hitting the guy from the and the balls
from behind with a stick
i didn't see that why is yesterday no
canadian game oh the canadian game dude
i i was so jet lagged i'm not so wiped
out from my tour i actually forgot
monday night's usually dark not only did
they have a game they played the
canadians i missed every second of that
i saw the capitals game i saw the flyers
game this week and uh who else did they
play i think they but luch dude what
luch he speared him from the back under
his butt like hit him in the taint the
guy went down like a house of cards
it was it was not it was not something
lucia could have put that in the
highlight reel i got to see that back
what a thing i i got to see that
yeah he sticked him underneath like it
was really i'm like luch what are you
doing
[Laughter]
well just so the people know we're not
going to just talk sports on on the tour
no no no
no no
no i don't even all my sports jokes are
i cut them out the nice thing
the great thing about this tour is like
we're all alike but our comedy's
different which is great i'm clean
all right well we're gonna we're gonna
have to wrap this thing up here soon i
want to talk a little little hockey
though anybody's not a sports fan it's
gonna be like what the [ __ ] with this
podcast i don't care let me just read
the last people this is your podcast
yeah but people still [ __ ] [ __ ] moan
there's always [ __ ] you know what it
really is it's just six people [ __ ] and
then i think it's like six million so i
mean i only have that is the math on the
internet by the producer of a show one
time he's like well like six people
that's really in the internet term
that's like four thousand yeah it's like
really what is that based on uh he was a
[ __ ] that's why i don't work with you
but based on how many if 10 people are
listening to six people [ __ ] not four
thousand
you know i'm not good at math
there's something in the internet though
is like one person equals hey let me
read this last let me butcher this last
one and we'll wrap this thing up here uh
hulu plus everybody you've probably
tried hulu.com hulu plus is so much more
that with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite shows anytime anywhere hula
plus lets you watch thousands of hit tv
shows and movies in the living room or
on the go with your smartphone or tablet
with hulu plus you can watch your
favorite tv shows like snl jimmy kimmel
live uh shark tank and scandal watch
every uh episode of shows like lost law
order svu
doctor who and community how old am i i
don't even know half those shows you can
also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals like the wrong
man's and behind the mask hulu's new
docu-series
that takes you inside the world of
sports of mascots behind the mask i'm
gonna watch that uh you also get access
to a collection of ad-free movies and
kids content for only 7.99 a month catch
up on current shows binge on old
favorites or catch great movies uh
stream as many tv and shows and movies
as you want wherever you want i don't
know what apps whatever else i got to
tell you here this stuff is great uh
make sure you use hulupus.com
bill so you get the extended free trial
and that they know we sent you once
again it's hulupus.com bill right now
for your extended two free week trial
all right there we go um
anyways
uh that's been the podcast for this week
i know it's difficult when we have three
four guys in here and all that so i hope
we didn't step on each other too much
for people listening out here but i'm
really psyched for you guys
thanks bill first of all i mean
everyone's just like amazed you know i
mean not amazed but i mean it's really a
nice thing that you did hey
appreciate it
you guys didn't read the fine print of
the uh the tour i'm gonna own the rights
to all your acts and uh your podcasts
you can have it
i've been trying to sell my account yeah
exactly
tonight uh tonight we're gonna be down
largo we're gonna give a great show and
then afterwards uh i brought some cubans
back from uh
canada so over my house over my house
you know we'll get a lot of shirley
temple
and the rest of us can drink a little
you know i mean johnny it's just like
you know you thought you'd hang around
with some adults once in a while in your
life you know it's funny as soon as you
said that we just yeah yeah it looks you
know
90 days that's it
89 89 days you might loosen your back up
a little bit no i don't know man i heard
it's good for it
a man with backstreet best thing if
you're not going to have like the real
real drugs best thing is like three
regular aspirin and a couple couple big
pops yeah a couple is that right yeah
best thing for my i'll tell you what the
day i i went in for it i was so jacked
up they shot me with morphine they put
needles in my back and i'm going to tell
you something i was like well listen
he's you know
i'm like a doc i i can't take it and he
was like that'll be a while to fill the
prescriptions he's like how do you feel
about needles i'm like i don't like them
but i even had a drink in like 80 days
so stick me wherever
he's like it's morphine i'm like please
have you ever had morphine shot into you
yes yes that's the greatest part just
did the greatest party i've ever had
it's instant like oh i had the morphine
drip and when you have surgery you just
hit the button and you get it and it's
just it goes away like it's it's it's it
broke my mind i jammed mine no you
didn't
that's the truth you rang it you rang it
on jeopardy with that thing yeah like
alex trebek was like a joke no no i just
i need more morphine i did you jam the
[ __ ] machine i did i jammed it i hit
it so many times that's hilarious it
only lets you like because it's only
supposed to do it every 12 minutes yeah
if you get like 12 minutes
like your lighters out of fluid like he
just he couldn't get a flame anymore now
wait a minute with that stuff do you get
high or do you just get nothing oh you
get high
high not numb it's not novocaine that
kind of jesus eye where you're just like
ah
[Music]
jesus
yeah you're too it's it's i never had
had it before all my life 40 years of
living plus and i've never had morphine
and that was awesome i mean i was like
three hours just like oh man that was in
the car wreck
uh three uh
a month ago so they my doctor was
worried about me going to new york and
walking around so he shot me up
and i was in the hospital with like four
guys were all lined up these
old guys like war veterans were like
came back to cry and like
their families were making fun of them i
went in there my back's been so jacked
i've had so much [ __ ] done to me he's
like you don't feel that you don't feel
that i'm like no
no no feel because well that's amazing i
came back and they were like you didn't
feel nothing like no you guys were like
that's amazing
they're a machine
indestructible you are joe you are
you're you're one of a kind well the uh
the show is tonight at 8 30. um i think
they're actually we got about 10 tickets
left that we're probably gonna release
around four o'clock if nobody else hits
us up for tickets so uh maybe you can
grab some last second ones but i'm
psyched to be working i don't think i've
ever worked with all you guys at the
same time i know new year's we came
close yeah bartnik lawhead and uh
feminists and then us three have done
yeah and that's three three of us
never all of us so here we go here we go
the four horsemen you can't make it
tonight if you're listening in san diego
yeah so please uh san diego you guys got
to give me a website where i can send
these people as far as
madhousecomedyclub.com
is for san diego i know that um
parlorlive.com
is uh there's helium
pdx i think dot com for uh
and then uh punchline sf.com and then
plus punchline sac for sacramento.com
yep okay and that's all for the first uh
the first uh the west coast leg of this
tour all right guys thanks for coming
down on the podcast and thank you man
it's on the studio you got a nice little
studio yeah all thanks comedy all things
comedy all right that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves and i'll talk to you
next week
you